c'est un nouvel accord historique
cette cérémonie de signature entre le
président afghan ashraf ghani et son
rival abdullah abdullah
met fin à plusieurs mois de conflits qui
ont plongé l'afghanistan dans une crise
politique
un nouvel espoir pour essayer de mettre
fin à plus de 40 ans de guerre nazisme
aujourd'hui est un grand jour historique
pour notre bien aimée afghanistan les
afghans ont prouvé qu'ils
réfléchissaient sagement et
collectivement à leur intérêt national
et ils ont trouvé leur unité au par
notre dame a déposé les dirigeants ici
présents ont fait beaucoup d'efforts et
sont en encouragements pour la
population afghane
il y a aucun doute sur le fait que la
communauté internationale soutient cet
accord politique tout comme les pays de
la région tâche en nommant abdullah à la
tête du conseil de paix qui va conduire
les pourparlers avec les talibans
l'accord fait renaître l'espoir d'une
avancée au sujet de l'entente conclue
entre les états unis les insurgés qui
ouvrait la voie au retrait des soldats
américains
si les opposants armés renoncer à la
violence et si des pourparlers s'ouvrait
avec kaboul cette nouvelle alliance
conclue ce dimanche a donc été saluée
par washington et la communauté
internationale heureux d'apprendre
qu'achraf ghani et abdullah abdullah ont
conclu un accord pour une gouvernance
inclusive
nous nous félicitons de leur engagement
à agir maintenant pour la paix en
afghanistan
je salue la décision des dirigeants
politiques de l'afghanistan de mettre un
terme à leurs différends et d'unir leurs
efforts pour former un gouvernement
inclusif
l'otan reste déterminée à aider
l'afghanistan instaurer une paix durable
le pays connaît une recrudescence des
violences dont une attaque contre une
maternité de kaboul la semaine dernière
qui a fait 24 morts dont plusieurs
nourrissons
notre défi auquel le pays doit également
faire face la propagation rapide du
ona virus dans la population
[Musique]